c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
enfin il imite les accents comme
personne ne voulait lire thaler a le
charme et rival idaho les deux c'est
quoi alors vous faites vous fait quoi
quand votre accent par sénégalais je
sais ce que tu veux allez-y faites vous
paye là portugais portugais et autres
qualifiés tombola sont des travaux tout
ça d'abord parce que matthieu delormeau
il regarde roddick et on dirait qu'il
est dans la france a un incroyable
talent y est comme ça ils aiment bien
l'accent quoi vous qu'en axant le mieux
l entier asie où la hâte en disant là ça
me fait vraiment plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
là
alors je vous le dis il nous a encore
fait sa tête jarillas il excédé
j'ai vraiment pas envie je danse il est
excédé quand il m'a donné la raison il
soulève au début j'ai dansé toute la
journée c'est toujours pareil à un
moment il faut mais comme ça hein
alors là oui mais là c'est la danse qui
rentrent en moi c'est la danse de
séduction a beaucoup appuyé ce que tu
fais comme ça ça va marcher en boîte ça
en bois seront annoncés les joies les
voilà les attentions à 17 h
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
voilà qu'en quillan où vas tu veux moi
je viens juste d'arriver drôle il danse
bien email mais ça me change de tout le
monde ici et ça voulait dire quelque
chose dit non mais dans le film minerai
très bien exactement
[Musique]